Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 267, wo wir heute an einem Wochenende Deutschland völlig umsonst zu einem besseren Platz machen, die Welt retten und das beste Computerspiel aller Zeiten programmieren. Was heißt das? Das heißt, wir reden heute über Hackathons oder Jams oder wie auch immer man das bezeichnet, wenn sich ein paar Leute für kurze Zeit auf einen Haufen setzen und versuchen möglichst kreativ zu sein. Und das hört sich ja alles total gut an. So eine Kreativparty quasi. Aber es wäre natürlich kein technisches Thema, wenn man das nicht auch völlig kaputt machen könnte oder missbrauchen sogar. Und wir reden heute über alles, was man damit anstellen kann, was das ist, wo es herkommt, wofür es benutzt wird und was man damit machen können sollte vielleicht. Anlass, also das Thema ist schon ein bisschen länger da. Anlass ist, dass es jetzt tatsächlich etwas gibt, das Update Deutschland heißt, wo versucht, wo eben genau das versucht werden soll, dass eben Leute zusammenkommen und dann in einem kurzen Zeitraum sich eine technische Lösung für ein Problem ausdenken können. Und ich bin, ich hab das, weil mein Kopf gerade mit anderen Themen voll ist, gar nicht so sehr verfolgt, sondern immer noch aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen, dass es da auch dann Kritik gibt, so Schlagworte wie, man kann für gesellschaftliche Probleme keine technischen Lösungen finden. Und mir scheint das Thema als besprechenswürdig. Und deswegen freue ich mich sehr, die heutigen Gäste begrüßen zu dürfen. Das sind Lilith, Julia und Stefan. Hallo und guten Abend. So, damit das geneigte Publikum, die HörerInnen euch kennenlernen können, wüsste ich jetzt gerne von jedem einzelnen von euch, wo ihr eigentlich herkommt, was ihr heute hier erzählen wollt und wie ihr mit dem Thema in Berührung steht. Also wo ihr herkommt, auch im Bezug auf das inhaltliche Thema. Keine ganz old written story. Julia, vielleicht fängst du an.
Genau. Und im Nachhinein gab es dann noch das Argument, als ihnen aufgefallen ist, dass das nicht so klug war, war das nächste Argument, dass das ja technisch überhaupt nicht anspruchsvoll und interessant sei, weil sie ja nur eine Wordpress-Seite gebaut haben.
Ich lass das einfach mal so stehen. Das ist ja...
Besonders fatal an der Geschichte natürlich auch der Abschluss, dass nämlich die Abschlusspräsentation quasi der einzelnen Ergebnisse dieses Hackathons in einem Video auf YouTube hochgeladen werden mussten und die Kommentare haben gezeigt, dass es doch recht starken anti-asiatischen Rassismus in Deutschland gibt. Und damit musste das Team alleine klarkommen und haben wenig bis gar keine Unterstützung von den OrganisatorInnen bekommen.
Also ich bin nämlich nicht 100% sicher, das kann sein, dass ich hörte davon, dass irgendwo ein Anwalt beauftragt worden sei, keine Ahnung was wie. Aber öffentlich lesbar ist halt nicht sonderlich viel davon. Aber ich kenn ja sozusagen von Hackathons, wo ich dabei war, tatsächlich nur Jugendhackt. Und ich habe die VeranstalterInnen immer so erlebt, dass eines der ganz großen Sachen da ist, dass das ein Safe Space ist. Also sowohl nach innen für die TeilnehmerInnen untereinander, als auch, dass sichergestellt wird, dass davon aus, was ich persönlich habe. Und mal abgesehen davon, dass ich persönlich das Verhalten absolut von Virus beziehungsweise den VeranstalterInnen indiskutabel finde, ist es zu vielverlangt zu sagen, also wenn ihr schon so ein großes Ding macht und dann auch noch so tut, als würde das sozusagen was für die Gesellschaft bringen, dass nicht da die Verantwortung liegt, um genau so was aufzufangen?
Das war auch die allgemeine Kritik. Also ich sehe das auch ganz genauso. Was so zurückgespielt wurde von den Leuten, die das damals organisiert haben, war ja, ja, wir haben das ja auch nur in unserer Freizeit gemacht, was natürlich totaler Quatsch ist, weil sie größtenteils irgendwie schon das auch beruflich machen oder zumindest in demselben Kontext. Und naja, wenn man irgendwie sagt, man macht eine Veranstaltung in dieser Größe, natürlich müsste man erwarten, dass sich die VeranstalterInnen darum kümmern.
Also ich glaube, die wurden auch von dem Andrang, der da kam, gerade eben auch aus dieser Perspektive raus, ich kann jetzt was tun, wurden die glaube ich auch komplett überrollt. Also die mussten auch glaube ich den CEO von Slack irgendwie auf Twitter anhauen, dass der die ganzen Menschen in ihren Slack-Kanal reinbringen kann, weil sie halt nicht irgendwie 18.000 Leute auf einmal in Slack einladen konnten. Okay, trotzdem keine Entschuldigung. Gerade wenn es im Nachhinein auch nicht so sagen besser geworden ist. Was war die andere Geschichte? Will ich die überhaupt noch hören? Hab ich noch genug Platz auf meiner Stimme für einen weiteren Facepalm? Ja. Lilith, komm, mach du mal.
Ja, also stell dir vor, du hast das Problem, du möchtest obdachlosen Menschen Geld geben. Und stell dir vor, du hast das Problem von, du möchtest eine Stadt sauber machen. Und jetzt machst du einen Hackathon, brainstorming und bringst das zusammen. Was wäre die schlechteste Idee, die dir dabei einfallen könnte? Richtig, du stellst einen großen Touch Queen in den Park und gibst Obdachlosen da irgendwie so Eurojobs von Kehr doch mal hier zusammen mit einem Besen, in dem man einen GPS-Tracker einbaut, damit man auch monitorieren kann, dass die wirklich kehren.
Mit KI.
Mit KI, richtig.
Ist auch eine Blockchain dabei gewesen?
Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr, aber ich würde wetten drauf abschließen.
Ich glaube nicht tatsächlich, aber... Also der Bäcker kann dann praktisch einen Microtask machen. Das Problem ist, dass Leute darauf angewiesen sind, Pfand zu sammeln und so weiter. Stattdessen könnte der Bäcker sagen bei mir vor der Bäckerei, das ist ein Zigarettenstummel und ich mache jetzt einen Microtask. Dann können die Menschen mit dem KI-enabelten Besen kehren und bekommen dann, glaube ich, Trockens. Wenn ich mich nicht ganz zertäusche. Die sind dann auch nur gegen Backwaren eintauschen können. Dieses Projekt wurde von der Vodafone-Stiftung verstetigt.
Was?
Was? Warte mal, lass mich zusammenfassen. Also, wir leben in einer Welt, in der manche Menschen so arm sind, dass sie keine Wohnung haben und Pfannflaschen sammeln müssen, um ihren Lebensunterhalt oder was auch immer sie brauchen, häufig erwerben zu können. Und statt zu versuchen, diese Welt zu verändern, sagen wir, hey, das ist doch mega gut. Wenn die kein Geld haben, können sie sich ja durch ihren Arbeitsethos wieder herausarbeiten. Und wie treiben sie in so eine Art... Ich will jetzt nicht Sklaverei sagen, weil das dann ein überstrapaziertes Bild ist. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich es sonst nennen soll.
Ähm, das hatte sogar noch einen weiteren Aspekt, fällt mir gerade ein. Sie wollten nämlich nicht nur Geld dafür bezahlen, um Microtasks zu machen, sondern sie wollten dir auch Geld dafür bezahlen, wenn du Verhalten an den Tag klickst, das sie gut finden. Also so was wie, du gehst zu einem Arzt und lässt dich da irgendwie durchchecken. Oder, ich weiß gerade die anderen Beispiele nicht mehr, aber sie hatten ganz viele Beispiele von, wie können wir Leute steuern, damit sie ein gesellschaftlich gewünschtes Verhalten haben.
Aber es war nicht so, dass man einmal pro Tag Blut abgeben musste, um dann den Arzt zu holen. Also, ist das die Quintessenz dieser staatlichen Hackathons? Die sind ja nicht staatlich, sie haben auch Schirmherrschaft. Also ich komm grade nicht so richtig klar. Ich glaub, man könnte das schon auch gut machen. Das ist glaub ich nicht das Problem. Und ich glaub, die Hoffnung war auch bei Weihweißes Virus, dass man da eigentlich in der Civic-Tech-Community auch Gehör verschafft, die seit Jahren sagt, so könnte man's machen, so ginge es besser. Ich glaube, die Beteiligten haben nicht damit gerechnet, dass da Menschen beteiligt sind, die genau in so einer Dimension denken, dass man Dinge durch Autopreneurship lösen sollte, vor allem. Und vor allem durch Privatisierung von Geschichten. Aber ist das nicht sozusagen das Problem, wie immer das Problem? Es gibt ein Projekt oder ein Konzept, das aus so einer, ich verwende das Wort jetzt mal im breitesten Sinne, hippiesken Idee kommt. Also hey, lass mal alle treffen und wochein zusammensetzen, vielleicht kommt da was Geiles raus. Dann wirft man Kapitalismus drauf und dann pervertiert das nicht in die hippie Richtung, sondern eben in die andere. Du hast eben, also ich musste gerade denken, was ich ja am Anfang schon gesagt hatte, da gewinnen halt die Leute mit dem buntesten Pitch Deck und der gewinnbringsten Idee, weil es dann anscheinend letztlich doch nicht darum geht, die Gesellschaft einen besseren Platz zu machen, sondern am meisten Gewinn abzuwerfen.
Ja, Gewinn einerseits oder halt irgendwie Image auf der anderen Seite. Also ich glaube, dass man das auch mit reinnehmen kann, dass es irgendwie gut aussieht.
So, jetzt ist ja das Thema der Sendung eigentlich Hackathon. Kann man also für diesen Anwendungsfall sagen nein? Oder glaubt ihr, es gibt eine Art und Weise, wie man dieses Format auf der Ebene gut einsetzen kann? Oder lasst mich die Frage anders stellen. Ich bin halt jemand, der sozusagen für Digitartechnik empfänglich ist, der klar ist, dass es keine gute Idee ist, Leute zu Microdrops zu verpflichten, die man in Chips einpflanzen. Meine Güte, wir sind ja wirklich fast so weit. Egal. Also ich bin jemand, der sagen, der technische Ahnung oder Verständnis oder Lust darauf hat und der weiß, dass man sozusagen mit Digitalisierung tatsächlich ein bisschen was besser machen kann, nämlich wenn man in diesen Civic-Tech-Bereich geht. Ich möchte also anscheinend nicht an so einem Hackathon teilnehmen. Was mache ich stattdessen? Ja, komm. Wer kann das? Das ist ja wieder die Ausschlussprobe. Ne, tatsächlich, also was man machen könnte, ist im ganz Kleinen, Campaigning. Also gerade dieser Punkt von wegen, es gibt schon ganz viele Beispiele, wo Dinge gezeigt worden sind, wie man das machen kann. Also ganz viel im Civic-Tech-Bereich ist ja auch so, da ist dieses Pattern, ich möchte das gar nicht auf ewig weiter betreiben. Also ich möchte nicht Entrepreneur sein, indem ich halt mal was besser mache, was die öffentliche Hand machen sollte. Und möchte jetzt Funding dafür einwerben. Manche sagen einfach nur, ich hab das gemacht und ich will eigentlich loswerden. Also das sollte die öffentliche Hand selber machen. Kleine Anfragen.de ist so ein Beispiel, wo Bundestagsanfragen erstmals richtig gut durchsuchbar waren und so weiter und so fort. Und das Ziel war da von Anfang an immer von wegen die öffentliche Hand, in dem Fall der Parlamentspiegel, soll das doch selber machen. Der hat das halt sechs Jahre nicht gemacht. Das heißt, hier wäre ein Ansatzpunkt, da muss man nicht programmieren dafür, da muss man nicht coden können. Das Einzige, was man machen muss, wäre da beim jeweiligen Bundestags- oder Landtagsabgeordnetenbüro anzurufen und zu sagen, hey, kennt ihr kleine Anfragen.de zum Beispiel oder vieles andere, was es da gibt? Warum ist das eigentlich immer noch nicht in der öffentlichen Hand und wäre doch Digitalisierung? Da kann man sich doch profilieren mit.
Und wenn ich es jetzt von der anderen Seite sehe, also wenn ich jetzt eine Verwaltung wäre oder höhere Institutionen, dann sind natürlich A, also ich schau einfach mal, was gibt es denn so? Was gibt es denn so für Ideen? Was gibt es denn so für Leute, die sich seit Jahren für ein Thema einsetzen, offensichtlich ohne sich großartig davon was zu versprechen in irgendeiner finanziellen Hinsicht? Also mal gucken, wer ist denn da? Und ich finde es immer so ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, wir machen noch eine Veranstaltung, weil viele Menschen haben dann halt doch auch eine Familie und ein Privatleben und auch mal Interesse, was anderes zu machen, aber warum nicht einfach Austauschplattformen irgendwie anbieten? Das kann ein Abend sein, das kann ein Barcamp am Wochenende sein, aber einfach wirklich ins Gespräch zu kommen mit den Menschen, die es halt schon sehr lange machen und halt nicht irgendwelche Ideen einfach nur anbieten wollen, sondern sagen, guck mal, das läuft irgendwie schon vier Jahre gut, aber ich bin jetzt fertig mit, weiß ich nicht, meinem Studium und eigentlich schon viel zu lange drüber und ich kann es nicht mehr betreiben. Wie kriegen wir es jetzt hin, dass ihr das macht?
Ich meine, ich bin ja ein Behördenmitarbeiter und mein Job ist, solchen strange Leuten, wie sie hier im Radio gerade sind, zuzuhören und halt ganz intensiv zuzuhören, was die denn machen. Also nicht meine Probleme abzuladen, meine Challenges, sondern mal anzuschauen, was es schon ganz real gibt und dann selber an den Klippen der Verwaltungen zerschellen, damit es die anderen nicht machen müssen. Aber bist du idealisierter Einzelkämpfer oder gibt es sozusagen das, was du machst, schon als regulären Job auch in anderen Verwaltungen? Ich bin da nicht der Einzige, um Gottes Willen. Ich war auch nicht der Erste. Also gerade im Code for Germany Netzwerk beispielsweise, wo ja ganz viele solche Gruppen vernetzt sind, da gibt es viele Menschen, die baden ihre Hände in Stadtverwaltung, in Kommunalverwaltung. Da gibt es auch Überschneidungen mit der Wikipedia-Community und so weiter und so fort. Also da bin ich überhaupt nicht allein. Was aber glaube ich viele von diesen Menschen eint, ist gerade so dieses Hände über den Kopf zusammenschlagen, dass statt der eigentlichen Baustellen jetzt so viel Fokus auf diesen Showveranstaltungen liegt. Ja, Leuchtturmfassaden-Projekte. Das ist so schlimm, wenn man immer wieder an diese Stelle stößt. Also egal, worüber man redet. Ich würde, bevor wir zum Abschluss kommen, Lilith noch mal fragen wollen. Du hast am Anfang erzählt, dass sozusagen dein, nicht Hobby, aber dein Aktivismus sozusagen in die Richtung geht. Es gibt irgendwie ein Gesetz, was e-Digitalisierung vorschreibt und dann machst du irgendwas. Könntest du das noch mal genauer beschreiben? Weil mir scheint es auch in die Richtung zu gehen. Was kann man machen, anstatt auf einen Hackathon zu gehen, auf so einen Hackathon zu gehen?
Genau. Ich hab mich letztes Jahr tatsächlich so halberuflich sehr intensiv angefangen, mit dem Online-Zugangsgesetz zu beschäftigen. Das besagt grundsätzlich, dass bis Ende 2023 alle Verwaltungsleistungen in Deutschland online angeboten werden müssen. Ja, das wird praktisch auch nicht passieren. Dazu hab ich eine ganz große Datenauswertung gemacht, wo ich aufgezeigt habe, dass wir momentan bei einem Umsetzungsstand von 3% liegen. Wenn man sich das komplette Datenframework als Online-Zugangsgesetzes nimmt, fand die Bundesverwaltung zum Teil ziemlich cool, dass ich das gemacht hab, zum Teil nicht. Ich hab mir daraufhin angeschaut, wo liegen denn da ganz konkret die Probleme? Die sind ganz vielschichtig. Wir bräuchten irgendwie einheitliche Formate über Strukturen, wie man sagt, nur sinnvoll gemeinsam, also über mehrere Kommunen und Länder und so weiter hinweg umsetzen kann, technisch, bis hin zu, ja, vielleicht wär's cool, Open-Source-Software zu haben, um viele diese Sachen zu machen. Dann hab ich mich hingesetzt und mal angefangen, als erstes so ein paar der Standards, die tatsächlich die Verwaltung bis heute schon entwickelt hat, rund um das Online-Zugangsgesetz mal in Open-Source-Software umzusetzen. Und hab da außenrum dann als erstes prototypisch mal ein Formularsystem gebaut, das halt für die öffentliche Verwaltung möglichst einfach funktioniert. Und keine Ahnung, ich hab dann über dieses Ding gemerkt, wie unglaublich viele Leute in der Verwaltung es eigentlich schon gibt, die sich mit Open-Source beschäftigen und die sowas richtig cool finden. Die aber halt häufig nicht auf Bundesebene sitzen, sondern die irgendwie auf Landes- und Kommunalebene sitzen. Und da gibt's dann so kleine bayerische Orte wie Treuchtlingen. Die machen seit 20 Jahren Linux auf dem Desktop, haben fast kein Stück Close-Source-Software mehr in ihren Systemen. Und ja, die machen das einfach. Und da laufen viele Sachen richtig gut, aber die brauchen halt irgendwie mehr Unterstützung, die brauchen mehr Infrastruktur und so weiter und so fort. Und mit denen macht es dann richtig Spaß, auch zusammenzuarbeiten. Und das ist dann halt auf einem ganz anderen Ebene, wo man einfach mit der Arbeitsebene, mit der Verwaltung zusammenkommt und nicht im Großen sich hinzusetzen und vor Bundestagsabgeordneten zu pitchen, die von all dem, was die wirklichen Probleme sind, gerade in der Verwaltung, häufig nicht weiter entfernt sein können.
Kann man das irgendwo öffentlich verfolgen, was du machst?
Ja, also Formularium heißt das Ganze. Das kann man auf GitHub sich anschauen. Und ich twittere darüber auch immer wieder. Und ich twittere auch über so Datenauswertungen und alles, was zum OZG halt so mir unter die Finger kommt.
Okay, da schreiben wir auf jeden Fall auch die Show notes. So, nachdem wir jetzt also darüber gesprochen haben, was Hackathons sind und wer sie momentan benutzt, um Aufgaben nicht zu erledigen, die eigentlich erledigt werden sollten. Was macht denn, vielleicht können wir sozusagen auch eine positive Note abschließen, was macht denn für euch einen guten Hackathon aus? Ihr solltet Rücksicht nehmen auf, wer dran teilnehmen kann und wer nicht. Also das fängt damit an, bei so ganz basic Geschichten, von wegen in Zeiten, als wir uns noch in der Hosenwelt alle trafen, hat es ja auch Abhängigkeiten, von wegen, wer kann sich eine Anreise leisten, wer kann sich eine Unterkunft leisten, sonst irgendwie. Das ist zum Beispiel schon mal ein Punkt, wo man über Stipendien auch was machen kann, um auch Leute, die sich sowas nicht leisten können, das zu ermöglichen. Kinderbetreuung ist auch so ein Punkt natürlich, der da eine Rolle spielt. Und selbst dann wird man auch viele, viele, viele Ausschüsse machen. Und was auch immer wieder heißt, dass ganz viele Teile der Gesellschaft nicht abgedeckt sind. Das mitzudenken ist schon mal kein Fehler. Es gibt da einen wunderbaren Vortrag Programming is forgetting, wo Alison Parrish sagt, wir müssen die komplette Hacker-Ethik neu denken und viel breiter aufziehen. Nämlich genau, wen lassen wir eigentlich aus? Das mindestens zu berücksichtigen. Und wenn es dann um die Umsetzung geht, wenn man wirklich sagt, ich möchte jetzt was langfristig weiterverfolgen, wo es nicht nur um meinen Lernspaß geht, es ist die große Aufgabe, erstmal zu schauen, wen gibt es da gerade schon, die sich schon lange mit den Dingen beschäftigen. Und wo ich beitragen kann. Du bist, glaube ich, jetzt bist du aber wieder bei dem, was können wir als Geschäft machen. Ich wollte jetzt wieder zurückgehen zum Hackathon. Zu den Ausrichtern? Genau. Was macht deinen guten Hackathon aus? Also wo wir nicht die Gesellschaft verbessern wollen als Hauptziel, sondern wo wir eine gute Zeit haben können und unser kreatives Hirn anschmeißen. Dann ist die Zielsetzung nur, ich möchte Leute zusammenbringen und vernetzen, oder? Das frag ich dich. Ich bin jetzt jemand, das Format klingt ganz cool. Was wir jetzt gerade gesagt haben, bei Update Deutschland möchte ich wahrscheinlich nicht mitmachen. Aber ich würde es machen, worauf ich achten soll, wenn ich einen Hackathon aussuche, an dem ich teilnehme. Was soll der können? Ach so, wenn du teilnimmst, okay. Da ist wieder die Frage, wenn ich nur laden will, dann ist doch genau der Punkt. Also dann reicht es ja auch schon im Endeffekt zu sagen, das ist ein Thema, dem ich für das ich mich interessiere. Und dann gehe ich rein und dann passt es. Und dann kann ich natürlich auch schauen, da kann ich auch die Veranstaltenden darauf aufmerksam machen, ob sie Leute, ob sie Ausschlüsse provozieren oder ob sie da entsprechend auch auf Zugegängigkeit achten. Das ist schon mal auf jeden Fall ein Vorteil. Aber ich glaube, da ist wieder der große Punkt, dass wir so ein riesiges Feld haben und wir echt dann schauen müssen, was ist eigentlich das Ziel, was ich verfolge. Lass mich die Frage anders stellen. Zu welchem Hackathon gehst du als nächstes und warum? Das wird derjenige Hackathon der Deutschen Bahn sein, der wieder in der Hosenwelt nach der Pandemie stattfindet irgendwann, weil man da schöne, witzige Leute treffen kann und ich Züge mag. Wobei, Bahn klingt auch schon wieder, Aha, Firma, naja gut. Ich glaube, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt an der Stelle, weil das ist einer, wo man sich gegenseitig parasitisch ausnutzt. Das ist nämlich ein ganz spannender Punkt, gerade bei Open Data. Ich meine, die Bahn hat natürlich was davon, wenn sie Leute zu sich ranzieht, und das natürlich auch Employer Branding und so weiter. Aber das ist so eine Geschichte, die kann man halt als Teilnehmende aus der Civic-Tech-Community high checken, weil ich dann auch sagen kann, schau mal hier, ich suche mir Beispiele raus, wo ihr zu wenige offene Daten draus gebt. Dann bohre ich irgendwo vielleicht Schnittstellen an, wo ich an die Daten trotzdem rankomme und sage, schau mal, hat niemandem wehgetan, bitte stell das auch als Open Data bereit. Also da kann man sich schon gegenseitig ein bisschen hochleveln. Das ist nicht die böse Seite. Alles klar. Lilith, wo willst du hin als nächstes? Dein Hackathon? Oder wodurch zeichnet sich ein guter Hackathon für dich aus?
Also ich glaube, dass einfach erst mal transparent sein muss, was das Ziel des Hackathons ist. Und dann sollte das auch noch ein Ziel sein, das nicht ist, wir verändern die Welt, sondern vielleicht wir lernen was zusammen. Das finde ich immer sehr schön. Jetzt ganz konkret durch die Pandemie weiß ich gar nicht, was der nächste Hackathon sein wird, an dem ich mal teilnehmen werde. Ich fände eigentlich Jugendhackt offline irgendwann noch mal ganz cool als Mentorin. Das habe ich vor ein paar Jahren schon mal gemacht und das fand ich sehr schön. Und sonst bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Na okay, aber Jugendhackt kann man ja auch schon mal in der Liste aufnehmen. Julia, ein guter Hackathon ist oder welchen Hackathon möchtest du als nächstes besuchen? Gerne sozusagen nach Rosenwelt Zukunft.
Natürlich auf jeden Fall Jugendhackt. Ich glaube, das ist einfach so mit das beste Konzept, was ich kennengelernt habe und dem ich eigentlich immer eher bestätigt. Sehr gerne würd ich ja auch mal so einen Mentor in den Jugendhackt sehen. Also dass wir dann einfach den ganzen Kram machen können. Und eine Sache, die ich tatsächlich auch sehr gerne mag, weil es dort tatsächlich solche Sachen gibt, wie zum Beispiel ein Stipendium für Leute, die sonst eher nicht auf Hackathons rumlaufen oder wo es auch mal Kaffee und Kuchen gibt und einfach Familien mit Kindern und allen Möglichen aus der Stadt gerade vorbeikommen können, ist der Hackday in Mörs. Zumindest hab ich den immer als sehr offen erlebt und dort auch so die ersten Workshops mitnehmen dürfen, wo dann irgendwie ein Thomas Tursich erzählt, was ist denn das eigentlich mit den offenen Daten und so die ersten Schritte kann man da, finde ich, sehr gut machen. Und da kann man auch sehr gut die nächsten Schritte gehen. Deswegen, wahrscheinlich Hackday in Mörs, so abgesehen von Jugendhack, was wahrscheinlich eh in meinem Herzen einfach drin ist.
Alles klar, also verschiedene Sachen heute gelernt. Was ein Hackathon ist, dass Jugendhack anscheinend der beste Hackathon der Welt ist und wofür man ihn nicht verwenden kann und worauf man sozusagen achten sollte. Vielen lieben Dank euch, dass ihr heute hier wart und mir so ausführliche Rede und Antwort und meine ganzen Fragenertragen habt gestanden habt. Vielen Dank Stefan, Julia und Lilith. Und mir bleibt zum Abschluss der Sendung nur noch eine ganz wichtige Sache zu sagen, die natürlich auch vor oder für Hackathons gelten. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüttelt immer schön eure Backups.